in the conversation okay sister
that's fine sister you can lose interest
if you like it is disappointing that a
woman who observes the hijab is here
number one rejecting a Hadith that a man
who says that they're a Muslim you know
and says that they listen to the Hadith
he's using scientific research to
justify horniness that is embarrassing
that is embarrassing so it's
embarrassing once it's embarrassing that
as men we have a higher sexual drive I
can imagine we're blame now you man look
religion
you get married
instructed me to download this app I
never knew that this app would have such
an impact on people's lives you can go
into the description box click the link
for IOS and Android and build your habit
with the Quran right now wait I'm equal
things equally good do you accept that
good so what I'm saying is the studies
that show this and we have Quran and the
Sunnah that says that a man the biggest
weakness is a woman biggest weakness
yeah now I'm giving a scenario so we can
understand I am walking down the road
with my wife at night time and a man in
a balaclava comes out and pulls out a
knife
is my wife in a vulnerable situation
what does she require me to do
protector if I run away what would
happen
she will call me a coward
you see okay let's stop there I haven't
finished my point before we stop that
never finish my point now in her most
vulnerable position I have to do what I
have to be there for her do we all
accept that does anybody have a
contention about that that when my wife
is in a situation or be that for any
woman if I see a Muslim woman and
there's a guy with a knife yes I would
step up or any man should step off the
defender do we all agree I agree good so
we agree that when a woman is in a most
vulnerable place that she requires a man
who is stronger than her to defend her
good now let's go to one second my
comparison let's go to the bedroom now
now in the bedroom the man is in his
most vulnerable situation when he needs
his wife intimately when a woman says no
she is as good as doing what I would do
to my wife if I run away in a fight do
you accept that no good now you don't
exclusive there I'm sorry you don't
accept it
let's talk about it one second what
point do you not accept
the fact that she's left in a vulnerable
state could have her life could be
harmed yes whereas a woman refusing sex
to a man is yes
irrelevant the point is this is
one second okay
I'm talking too much I'll stop talking
guys guys
let's see can we let her talk can we let
it talk
I never
[Music]
are you speaking on my behalf uh behalf
of all the men you can't
[Applause]
one of the scenarios the woman is
spiritually sanctioned if the man runs
away as a coward he's not being
spiritually sanctioned and I think that
was your point so why is it a case that
in one situation there's a sanction in
the situation there's there isn't so
it's a societal context maybe saw them
out but spiritually he's not being
encroached in any way shape one second
he is putting his life on the line he's
about to die for his wife
If he if he doesn't protect his wife in
that moment yeah will he be sanctioned
will he be sanctioned yeah of course
people call the coward no would it be
spiritually
well Allah says
he's sinful
he's sinful
foreign
if a man doesn't protect and he doesn't
provide he's sinful because Allah tells
him men are the maintainers and
particles of women my job is what of
course if I if I don't provide shopping
for my house I don't pay the rent I am
transgressing the rights of my wife
and I'm with my wife I run away I'm
sinning you are because
you are sinful because you are the
maintainer and protector now please
please please please please please
please please sister assistant
guys We're not gonna have a friend who
discussion if we speak over each other
please
because
okay okay am I speaking to you about him
I'm gonna speak to you from now on
nobody else get involved okay sister
carrier no no don't anymore species I'm
speaking to you please go through
yeah
what's your point system
s
you know what
yeah you did this with me no I'm not I'm
addressing the points
no problem
Sister Sister
the prophet sallallahu said I agree the
biggest weakness for a man
it's not money it's not a house it's not
a car speaking for all men for every
single man that walks this Earth
because we follow Islam because we
follow Islam we follow what the
messenger of Allah said so therefore and
forget that I can show you studies
probably I'm going to read you a study
now I don't know one second one second
one second one second
study yeah not Google yeah Google yeah
Google's scholar no problem you can call
me milkshake if you love this strawberry
flavor yeah no problem now let's read
the study sister sister sister sister
please listen
I'm gonna read it please listen
carefully yeah
okay let's put Quran Sunnah for a side
for now
a sex drive please listen carefully
sisters please the sisters that belittle
a man's sex drive you can just control
it let's listen a sex drive refers to
the strength of sexual motivation across
many different studies and measures men
have been shown to have more frequent RP
again more frequent and more intense
sexual desires than women understood let
me carry on as reflective and
spontaneous thoughts about sex frequency
and variety of sexual fantasies desired
frequency of intercourse desired number
of Partners masturbation lacking for
various sexual practices willingness to
focuses initiating verses refusing sex
making sacrifices for sex and other
measures listen carefully
no contrary I repeat again n o not k n o
w n o
no no no no no look look do you see he's
just basically saying he only talk no
contrary findings indicating stronger
sexual motivation among women were found
now I'm going to read that whoa
no contrary findings indicating stronger
sexual motivation among women were found
hence we conclude that the male sex
drive is stronger than a female sex
drive last sentence last sentence last
sentence the gender differences in sex
drive oh yeah that's something else okay
now this is
non-muslims carrying out a study now
these two are special cases
one second we said that when it's when
it's when it's a man and his wife
please allow me because you know why
well I know I know but if I don't make
these players they're gonna jump to that
please please now I've quoted a study
not Google this is a study I can give
you the reference now
well when a man is in danger a woman is
in danger all the sisters go he has to
protect she said I'd rather die with him
than running away
one second one second no that's not no
that's not that is an aspect of a man to
protect his wife now now now now
guys guys guys sister sister sister
sister one second why is the double
standards and why is this hypocrisy
sister sister please I'm talking to your
sister please listen
why is it and this is what really annoys
me about some sisters not all when her
life is in danger he better be there
protecting me I don't care if he has a
1847 I don't know if he cares a pistol I
don't give you as a knife you have to
defend me okay I'll sacrifice my life
and die for you but when I come to use
the bed for intimacy you can say no to
me and when you say no to me and the
angels trust me come on get out of here
now please tell me sister please reveal
my points in now tell me why is my
comparison and the studies I've given
wrong
[Music]
you know there's not negate the idea I
want to get the point that horniness is
the feeling that you can control Allah
tells you to control it lower your gaze
when you see a woman that's a joke
you know if you marry the woman I know
you're using this Hadith and you're like
okay but you said
right seriously control yourself
control themselves
brothers did she listen to me when I
spoke
the problem did she listen to me when I
spoke sorry she was quiet okay then why
are we to play when she said I'm sorry
listen to her guys she's making a point
please listen Wala is not nice she
listens to go and I spoke I know but
when you do that the topic go somewhere
else
and I'm waiting
she is also cursed by the angels from
behind her walking within she is cursed
I don't know that Hadith can you mention
to me I don't remember if a woman
no no I don't know about her job
you divide himself in fragrance and
wears heels
no no
can you rebuke the point that I mean
let's stick to that remember okay the
point the point okay the point the point
the point the point was very clear yeah
[Music]
a man's wife wants intimacy
if a woman came here today and said you
know what my wife my husband is not
giving me sex voila you guys will cause
outrage
[Music]
check this out check this out when a man
was intimacy from his wife he should be
patient when a woman was intimacy from
his husband there's outrage no she
should be patient as well the man should
be patient the woman should be patients
Sister Sister we follow Islam and in
Islam a woman came to the prophet peace
be upon him and he said to the prophet
my husband doesn't sexually satisfy me
the prophet gave allowed her to have
divorce her right is intimacy you have
no right to deny his intimacy now you
can choose to if you want to say no
that's up to you but guess what she has
a right to go and get divorced if she
goes to a scholar and says my husband
doesn't look look
sister we don't follow your opinion we
follow Islamic let me make that clear if
a woman goes to the Sheikh and says my
husband look does it give me sex he
doesn't sexually satisfy me meaning he
does but he doesn't satisfy me she has a
right to seek divorce not a single man
here I could tell her oh what kind of a
woman are you shut up she has a right
for intimacy he's not pleasing her she
has a right to divorce what would the
feminists do whoa talk bear come on guys
but with this a man be patient control
your desires hypocrisy so sister once
again now let me ask you a question in
this scenario let's go to the scenario
of the Angels cursing the woman who is
here to blame check this out as a Muslim
man guys are we allowed to have
girlfriends Brothers I'm talking to you
hello I will not have girlfriends side
chicks Mistresses meaning what we have
to lower our gates so it's not like the
non-muslim men who are like you know
what I'm bored of my wife let me go and
sleep around we can't do that so when
we're out and about or for example we
desire a woman a wife no no I'm sorry
sister sister
you know why because if a man is going
home can you imagine protecting himself
no in this case provides for her
financially Works aimless
comes home and says can we have intimacy
and she goes no who is oppressing who
she is oppressing him
exercises
so you're changing the topic I'm always
talking about perfume sister
I'm not talking
what is your problem with the angels
angels cursing the woman that is abusing
her husband by not giving him intimacy I
don't want to have sex
did you did you hear the study that
showed it okay
I don't care okay good good check this
out you know what she's saying you know
what she's saying go and violate Allah's
laws but I'm not going to give you what
you want they'll tell you something a
woman like that let me tell you
something
is Haram
you're seeing him go come here check
this out guys
sister sister sister sister sister
sister guys are we all men what's that
what's that what's happening one second
are we men
how hard is it for us to control our
sexual desires
brother probably you're a different type
of man yes man you must be futility
though no I'm so sorry if you're telling
me you're not like that Dennis I'm so
sorry if you're saying that you're lying
bro are you a Muslim yes okay I'm sorry
forgive me I thought he was a regular
forgive me I take it back I didn't know
I didn't know forgive me forgive me
forgive me forgive me
I apologize on camera I apologize to
this brother and I asked him to forgive
me check this out a man provides
protects he he works endless knives pays
the rent electricity bill looks after
this family Etc and he comes home and
this is his wife and he just wants
intimacy and guess what does the Hadith
say force yourself upon your wife no he
doesn't it just says if he's angry the
Angels curse and what's that sister
saying no even if you provide protect
this that no sense what kind of a planet
are you living on what kind of plan are
you living on and this is the hypocrisy
of feminism the disease of feminism
that's infiltrating our sisters that
this country my sister in hijab
unbelievable a woman let me tell you
something and I'll tell speaks to my
other sisters as well yeah you imagine
you have a husband you look after the
kids you make you look after him you're
good to him you're loyal to him and you
do all of this and when you're on the
road the man pulls out a knife he says I
don't have a right I don't need to
protect you how would you feel how would
you feel sisters I'm asking you would
you be happy would you be happy sister
no you wouldn't look these are our
sisters at least I haven't been affected
by this yeah but the point is this my
dear sister is still there
my dear sister does anybody agree with
what this is saying look let me give you
an example yeah and maybe you will
understand yeah my dear sister my dear
sister
my dear sister are you still in the
conversation okay
rambling I'm losing that's my sister you
can lose interest if you like it is
disappointing that a woman who observes
the hijab is here number one rejecting a
Hadith that a man who says that they're
a Muslim you know and says that they
listen to their Hadith he's using
scientific research to justify horniness
that is embarrassing that is
embarrassing so it's embarrassing once
it's embarrassing that as men we have a
higher sexual drive I can imagine we're
blame now you men
you get married no way in Islam
sister can you show me where in the
Quran of the Hadith
what are you talking about so okay one
second it's bad to be horny I won't have
intimacy with your wife sister what
planet do you live on one life I didn't
say
it and why didn't you come out
you know the idea that they're obligated
to give it to you or the idea that not
obligated because the Hadith would say
force yourself upon her because it says
no it says if the husband said can we
have intimacy she says no he goes sleep
upset the Angels cursor you're not even
you know what she does the Angel's not
even allowed to curse her get upset upon
the man to get upset okay no problem one
second I'm gonna give you another same
example you have a husband he provides
protects good to the kids shopping rent
everything you provides for you you walk
down the road a man pulls a knife he
says I am not obliged to protect you
would you be upset
would you be upset of course look look
look look look at this
my dear sister that husband of yours or
whoever this man he will move on with
another woman
I tell you if your wife
look at her she goes I would be upset if
my husband after doing all of that being
married to him for so long look look
look I'll be upset but if a man is upset
no no no no no no no
well like do you guys agree with that
all I'm going to say is
sorry but if the wife has a valid
reasons if the wife has a valid reason
of course sister thank you now look our
sister may Allah bless her is reasoning
if a woman is heavily pregnant if she's
on her period if she's been working all
day looking after the kids like even
then there can be a compromise they can
be understanding yeah at least there is
understanding because we're not seeing
she's working uh like she's working
after three kids the man Works come home
and help your wife cater for that make
put the kids no no it's not fine sister
what she saying may Allah blessing were
you see in a mountains apart why
against Islam
what your sins against Islam because
you're saying you know why sister sister
sister sister sister that woman is
abusing sexually her husband if a man
let me tell you and any feminist would
agree
ment for saying no to sex
no no no no sister sister if a woman is
sexually frustrated and her husband is
saying to her no no no no no
I even my check if this woman ended up
falling into Haram yeah the scholars
might even maybe maybe even blame the
man and say okay what happened my wife
committed dinner she shouldn't okay why
and the woman says this man hasn't given
me sex for two years the scholars will
turn to him and say what kind of a
Taiwan are you animal you are you're an
animal
this woman she has a right to intimacy
yeah and you've been saying no to her
no no no she doesn't if a woman comes
and he can reject her and she has a
right not to be angry she celebrated
she's still flowers in the air oh come
on sister what are you talking about
please and by the way the reason why I'm
so harsh forgive me is because this
ideology is penetrating intellectually
our sisters yes you are watching at home
and gain this idea of yeah
what is it look look look and this is
the issue if you're if your husband went
and got a second wife you blame him
foreign
[Music]
just the way you said you'll be
disappointed and upset with your husband
if he doesn't defend you
then why are you saying why is he angry
with me if I don't give him sex
yeah
so one second one second one second the
prophet said the prophet sallam said the
woman gets cursed what's your problem
do you have a problem with the mission
of Allah
the Carson part is Sister Sister
at the end of the day do you have a
problem
I do have a little bit of a problem with
that you have a problem with Alana's
messenger this is feminism
sister if Sister if the prophet stood in
front of you and said my dear sister
the prophet came to you and said
no no sister sister if the prophet came
to you and said my dear sister if your
husband wants intimacy and you don't
give it you are cursed what would you
say to him say that again if the message
of Allah was in front of you and he said
these exact words that if your husband
who provides and loves and protects you
and he wants and he says and he says
that he wants intimacy yes no he does he
means he's cursed
all night dangerous cursor of course he
does yes it does it does mean that it
does mean that it's actually it's not
the scholars say anytime the messenger
mentions curse is a major sin so one
second was it sister sister brother okay
okay please listen okay let's not show
up for our religion please
say you are cursed he's just saying what
okay okay is the Angels cursing the
woman
I'm not shouting now if the messenger of
Allah said that to you yes what would
you reply to him
if he said the woman will be cursed till
the morning for rejecting his husband
what would you say to him
okay
alhamdulillah
now what I'm saying is this but why are
you so upset about this
Mission okay
what is the issue where you are look let
me tell you something I can even put it
like this too yeah
I believe a woman
who has been good to his her husband
very good looks after kids and walking
down the road and her husband runs away
to Allah I will not blame that woman if
she said may Allah curse you
because you know why she was our most
vulnerable that man could have killed
her and voila you know what if she said
I'm gonna divorce him I'll say sister
you know what light is mad his mind is
the coward I believe he is everybody's
duty to protect one another if that's
your friend you're not going to run away
are you no it's your wife he runs away
friend if it was your friend you did the
same which one's closer friend or wife
depends
I have my friends I have my brothers
yeah but my wife who shares my life with
me has children with me she's apart come
on she's my like what I'm trying to say
come on no no no no no no if I did while
the entire Muslim Community her parents
my dad my friends were all flipping with
me they're with me in public they say
you are a coward for leaving your wife
and run away like a coward they will
whip me you know what I'll say you know
what I'm saying to them
no no what I'm saying is this the point
is this the same thing would happen yeah
but you are you I just cannot believe
the way you undermine a man's sexual
urges just because you know what it is
you know you know what it is it's like
me saying
it's not me saying this sisters why are
you guys talking about your pregnancy I
need to just push it out can you push
that out yeah you're making such a big
deal
the feminist Community will come here
and stole me next week if I belittled
you know why I don't know how is to be
pregnant I don't know what it takes why
do women come and say like they come and
tell us how bad it is it's as good as
having 30 or 40 of your bones
um broken or something like that imagine
me belittling that you are belittling a
man's sexual urge by saying what's the
big deal come on you are just using a
woman who should I use sister go and
sleep with her I would be like to other
women you know off
my tablet my blood sugar levels have
gone up
I got blood pressure bro
why are you blaming me I was involved
with the sexual I didn't say hey let me
be
a sister it's better now we stop it now
okay
more knowledge no no she accepted she
said no she said she said she accepts it
yeah okay
how old is
17. you're still young mashallah are you
are you a river
are you born alhamdulillah
the reason I'm saying this yeah and
sometimes I'm a little bit harsh you
know why she stopped because at the end
of the day I want the best for you if
this was my own sister if this was my
own sister yeah brother one second
ignorant ignorance if you was my own
sister I would do the same you know why
because I want the best for you it's
because our conversation is not just
here 30 people millions are going to
watch this and imagine a sister at home
who's watching this and going well hold
on a second I need to make these points
so the sister at home or the brother
number one the brother knows his duties
that he's a maintain and protector he
should never run away when his wife's in
danger yeah it's the same way we're
seeing we just want consistency if I'm
willing to put my life on the line and
die for you my wife when I come home and
I want intimacy man I want a mere
intimacy bro I'm dying at one I'm gonna
can you imagine me on Diner one the
other one is oh I chew I just don't want
to give you it one is an option the
other one is I have no choice but to put
my life on the line and I might die I'm
willing to die for you and you're not
willing to give me intimacy
what kind of Oppression is that
the main key key difference is life and
your nature which one's worse
are you afraid of that yes I'm very
afraid of that
actually verify well we are there's a
Hadith for the person from she even said
I'm afraid of death as well but that
doesn't mean you don't want to meet
Allah we're all there because I don't
know what death entails inshallah go
Jannah I'm scared you know may Allah
accept him away from a sinner of course
I'm gonna be scared I mean someone who's
not scared of death
increase my mind like yours like maybe
perhaps I'm having a difficulty there's
a mental flock between your example of
dying and protecting no no no no no no
no okay you're seeing peace one second
just to check this out yeah if I if a
man dies for his wife
in about a couple of months a year she's
going to move on with another man
no no no no one second the plane is in
one scenario the man dies janaza you
know is finished
in the other scenario the woman is just
choosing not to give intimacy for what
reason a valid reason is understandable
and what my man says I'm heavily
pregnant I've got back ache I'm not
feeling well I've been looking after the
kids understandable which animal will go
and say no you have to no what I'm
seeing is this is an unreasonable moment
and guess what do you know what this
Hadith shows it shows that the woman is
the transgressor and using sex to
Blackmail the husband
that's what she's doing so I don't know
how how the Hadith is made to seem as if
the man is wrong this is showing how a
woman is transgressing
no no I'm saying this is showing that
the woman is the one who's saying no for
no reason
about victimizing each other I thought
we made clear no no we made it clear
that what the had he said we accept it
and you accepted it
always accepted the Hadith I was just
arguing about the nuances of the Hadith
no no why would you argue with your
sister argue something you don't believe
in do you believe in it do you believe
in it
yeah I could believe in it but it
doesn't mean I could believe in her
sister so I had it it's like it's the
message
you believe that angels will cast you if
you say no and the man sleeps angry
because you don't want to don't they
don't want to have sex with him you can
believe that yes I don't know you could
believe that do you believe that
why does my belief have two oh yeah
let's say yes yes no no no don't say yes
I'll try to make you understand if you
want to carry on and reject a Hadith
from the prophet sallam because for some
reason because a woman a woman is
violating her husband by not giving
interviews and by the way the Hadith
doesn't say oh man go and force yourself
he says no go to sleep angry okay can
you imagine this
I said forgive me again once again one
light is because I care about you about
my own sister sisters sisters sister
sister
just just leave it please just act like
somebody's farting just like do this the
wind goes away please yeah so so what
I'm saying is this year the moment the
reason why there's these gender Wars
happening is because men are not men
anymore and women are not women anymore
okay the the rose have reverse so what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
tell the ummah you know how many
devotions Muslim couples
they go in same as non-muslims why
because men are not men woman and a
woman anymore
is it because some men and some women
are using their femininity or their
masculinity in the name of Islam to take
advantage of each other which one is it
which one that can be the case as well
for example a woman can take the
advantage of femininity by blackmailing
the husband how by the Hadith that we
gave if the husband says come I won't
have intimacy with you and she says no
she's blackmailing him with a femininity
do you accept that good and now a man
with his masculinity will come and say
no the Quran said you have to stay at
home shut up boom or whatever it may be
yeah there's understandings
is mature to you that is the biggest
reason why the focus has happened no I'm
just saying that could be one part I'm
saying that could be one point of it but
you said that most of it is because
women aren't acting like women and men
no I know because why because women want
to be boss babes and men want to be
simps men are happy yeah you go work
I'll stay at home that needs to change
now into this Society men are becoming
more
more like women feminine
feminine they're becoming more or less
extreme in their beliefs what kind of
beliefs
leadership being mastered how could you
how could you be extreme are you talking
about toxic masculinity yeah No Such
Thing exists what about toxic femininity
no no no no no one second toxic what's
toxic masculine masculinity
why don't we have toxic femininity why
would it no we don't no we don't we do
not
we do not have it so I'm asking why the
double standards toxic masculinity okay
let's suppose it exists what is toxic
masculinity you know what toxic
masculinity you know what it's the the
Line is now being a man to be a man to
say I want to be a traditional man toxic
masculinity huh a traditional man that
imposes on the rights of women that is
toxic what do you mean by imposes
does a man have a right to tell his wife
that he doesn't want her to uh not wear
lipstick or he doesn't want her to wear
no hijab or doesn't want her to wear
tight clothes is that toxic familiar in
masculinity
it becomes toxicity in persism no no one
second one second one second he is
allowed to say that to her he's
here and and she
can and guess what if a woman if a man
is going out topless his wife can tell
him
it is impulse she has to impose it on
him
but that's okay let us know he has to
because she's now telling us foreign
his wife you're wearing red lipstick
it's I don't like it I don't want you to
wear it if you do I will divorce you
manipulation no problem no problem no
problem
he does have a right to you okay good
can a woman
okay can a woman now come and say
um you are sometimes speaking to sisters
and you're I don't like it and if you do
I will seek divorce is that could she do
that
she can't do that why is it why
shouldn't why is he speaking to another
girl
what about sisters he calls him sisters
maybe he's trying to move to them okay
then you know what he's going to start
with I'm trying to give a tower by using
that assumption and yes
to yourself yeah if we're using that
assumption then yes she should she
should threaten because we're going oh
but that's why losing all right because
why is he I mean if it's a second wife I
mean still a bit big but at least
there's big fish the ways to go about it
but if he's continuously talking to that
different girls come on you're violating
the rights why are you speaking to other
girls why are you speak other girls so
the thing is here she has a right to
force him in in a specific instance and
say if you carry this on I will seek
divorce and she will have a right to
divorce but it doesn't mean you should
do it what do you mean okay all right no
problem
um speak to girls
um do what you like you go out in mini
skirts
you have the right to drink alcohol
everyone you have the right go go on but
you are being Haram you're being Haram
no no but look we are we are the leaders
and we will be responsible
because then you don't have that right
then but you know I don't have that
right of course I have that right
no no there isn't I have a right to tell
my wife that I don't want to wear
lipstick
period
no I can't do that I will do that
for you that's what I'm saying though
that's the point do I become toxic
masculine now am I am I a misogynist now
um no of course I'm not gonna go hey
don't worry a man's gonna shank you up
I'm gonna say look you know in a
romantic way you know maybe give a
little flower there it was you know I'm
gonna make lasagna today and I'm joking
yeah
you know what look I don't like you
wearing that okay
because I love you you're my wife I
don't want next man looking at you
because you're the reason I'm gonna go
back no you're not wearing it come on
there's a way of delivering it I'm
trying to say and it's the same with
you I know but he has a right to say
that and a woman
so when the woman has a right to say I
don't appreciate that you are messaging
these girls
so we're on the same page yeah yeah good
what are we arguing over
you tell me are we on the same thing
that's all I'm saying
you thought you think that I don't
accept some part of Islam it was when we
first started
I accepted it yeah
you have to completely take it full
Allah says in the Quran
Allah says in the Quran when Allah and
his messenger decides something it is
not for the believer to oh no no no did
he say it like why is he known as a
Sadiq because the quraish came to me
said you know you're you're companion
the prophet he said he flew to Jerusalem
bro look at this one life is so deep he
goes you know what he said to them he
goes did he say that because yeah I
believe it that's how we should be
anyway sister may Allah bless you you're
still young you're 17. yeah what I'm
saying is the rise Islam has given you
keep to that because that's the best
thing you have no feminism red pill none
of this stuff is going to give you to
the men and to the woman there's nothing
they're going to offer that Allah is
Messenger hasn't the moment we stick to
that which we have hamdullah bless you
we would Prosper the moment we start
doubting to be like that doesn't make
sense to me is where we're going to go
into Avenues where you can even leave us
sometimes forgive me uh but yeah that's
it that's what I want to say inshallah
foreign